thank you yeah where you go check out
pink gorilla it's a use video game shop
in Seattle they're like three or four of
them somehow the city maintains a chain
of franchises for these things they're
gonna have a booth of the show floor but
this store is pretty small and
apparently it has not been ransacked for
the show sort of hoppity cap and go
check it out might find some CDI games
for Jeff Gerstmann he's lucky and maybe
I'll find some Japanese games for myself
this is the store right here I don't
know how to get inside this place
hey it's gonna need Colin hi I'm Peter
nice to meet you too
yeah thanks willing this film it's gonna
roam around for a bit I guess cool
thanks
what am I looking for man I'm looking
for pretty much anything Genesis games
Saturn games PlayStation games you name
it
Nintendo anything they got a pretty good
selection Japanese stuff here that let
me ask you this do you guys have any CDI
games on hand I got a special request
from a friend the sad thing about
Genesis games wherever you go it's it's
almost always all sports titles it's
always all sports titles and like jungle
strike and desert strike yeah basically
I go to flea markets now every weekend
it's it's not good with yeah it's pretty
it's pretty rough this is the good stuff
for the problems and you collect a lot
of games you tend to have mostly I don't
have that doesn't did you guidance you
there you go yeah Ninja Gaiden 2 over
here we also have a bunch of Famicom
which is the Japanese Nintendo bunch of
those games over here as well like this
is the Japanese duck hunt it actually
has the earth from the game on there
and the one weird thing about Famicom
cartridges they all come in different
shapes depending on the publisher so
like Bandai will make a really big ones
like this this other company Iran will
have like a little red light on them
because the Famicom didn't have a power
light so they installed that on there so
when you turned it on you could actually
know that your systems I mean nothing
you couldn't see it on the TV already
but yeah
and this is a weird one by Konami they
don't usually make them this big I don't
even know what this game is you ever
played this before
Gani site never even heard of it
I'm a big Konami fan I have no idea what
that is the densha de go controller so
that's a controller for a train
simulator then it goes through a lot of
it like the stations that people you
know commonly visit yeah and it's like
really strict on the whole like you know
if you go like a foot past the stop so
you failed it's really specific right
now I think the biggest thing is just a
Nintendo 64 games accessories and
consoles really like I don't think we've
had in is no 64 controller a console in
for a couple of weeks now they just show
up on shelves and get bought up by
college kids who are moving their dorm
for the first time and have that little
dose of nostalgia that they want to
build yeah I mean and plus you guys have
good prices - yeah we try and keep our
prices competitive with what you can
only play like we're getting rich - so
we don't want to be just trying to screw
people out of all their money and how
many locations are there about there for
now we have this one the International
District the original one than our
university district West Seattle and
also our newest Bellevue store instead
we're just a small enough thing that we
can kind of be the anti gang stuff
Gamzee go let's see I got Advance Wars
days of ruin it's a strategy game from
we've Hal laboratories or the guys who
make Kirby one of Nintendo's publishers
Ninja Gaiden 2 one loves that [ __ ] and
Mega Drive game Wonder Boy 3 monster
lair it's a side-scrolling action a game
that's all pretty fun but the best thing
here is just kind of seeing a store like
this actually surviving and the fact
that there's three more of this in the
city and they're so popular that they
have enough inventory to bring to a show
floor for a booth but still keep their
stores open is really impressive you use
video games old video games have become
like really popular to collect now it's
really competitive and people are
charging a lot of money P Carrillo is
charging a fair price so I wish we had
something like this in San Francisco and
I'm really jealous at Seattle does so
yeah these probably will be the last
games I box I'm probably to go those
other stores and definitely their booth
at PAX